security is going to continue to grow
for a very long time I've challenged the
team to build a pretty aggressive plan
over the next few years I think that we
should continue to see growth and I
believe it will only continue to be a
greater percentage of our business we'll
see if it can become the predominant one
that would be great if it does but I
certainly see multi-year growth in that
business Chuck I know that your goal is
to restore sis going to double-digit
growth going forward how close are you
do this now and what how much of a drag
is your hardware business you're
switching business on that goal well
David if you look at our switching
business it really falls into two
different categories we have our campus
switching which is sort of the bread and
butter it's about two-thirds of the
business and that business is highly
driven by technology refresh cycles and
when you see uncertainty in the macro
environment like we see today customers
tend to pause on that but if you look at
the other third which is our data center
switching portfolio which is a 4 billion
dollar run rate business our orders this
past quarter grew in double digits our
security revenue grew seventeen percent
our collaboration business which is over
four billion annualized grew ten percent
our services business grew eleven
percent so we had some real bright spots
and in the switching space in particular
I think that data center switching
performance says that customers also
really buy into this notion of a hybrid
cloud world which means that they're
taking advantage of public cloud
services but they continue to build out
private cloud infrastructure as well
although the data center growth has
decelerated well if you look at our data
center switching portfolio it's actually
accelerated over the last few quarters
if you look at our computer with UCS
which is our compute in the data center
there is a transition going on there
that we are addressing with some new
technologies over the next few quarters
but our switching business in the data
center has been accelerating over the
last few quarters you've cited weaker
growth globally as one of the potential
headwinds where specifically as it's
coming from well we all know that there
are lots of geopolitical dynamics
going on you've got the Briggs it vote
coming up we've got uncertainty that
continues to exist in Brazil and Russia
we actually have seen great strength in
China and India and Mexico over the last
few quarters you've got the interest
rate discussion that you were having
earlier and so there are a lot of
dynamics that our customers are trying
to digest so what we see our customers
that are actually moving on very
strategic initiatives because they know
that this technology transition that's
occurring is not going to wait for
anyone and they all believe that the
technology will allow them to service
their customers better know more about
their customers give them the ability to
have greater tighter relationships with
their customers and give them a
competitive advantage so on the
strategic initiatives they're still
moving but there is a lot of caution in
the system based on these dynamics Chuck
you've talked about macroeconomic
uncertainty several times i'm going to
pin you down SQ unfair question very
short if you had to pick one one
McCracken actually what's the one that
bothers you the most I said it was
unfair as I looked well no it's not
unfair as I look at the dynamics I think
that the overall the global economy in
general and the growth rate of the
global GDP is probably the singular
issue and that is impacted obviously by
lots of different things but i think
that is by and large the issue i sent on
the call that you know we executed well
in a very uncertain environment but we
are also very nicely positioned with to
be a beneficiary of any recovery in the
global economy